or are no shoulds in toilet oh you have
to do is you can I can't see it well I
know that it's got to be somewhere let
me put in a tiny there it is Colin I
found there's two kinds of people in
this world and frankly they're not
thrilled with each other over or under
it's debatable I think it's totally fine
if the toilet paper hangs underneath
just like this debate I'm over the only
way to holster your toilet paper is over
and I fight for the opposition now I'm
for over and I'm team under that's just
the way you go to janitor school what
they teach you this is one on one type
[ __ ] when you have a turd hanging out of
your anus you want to be able to get to
that paper as quickly as possible
I would say you should let it drop into
the water first you need one swift
motion of an over to see how many pieces
you need and that's a girl
we need pieces you can immediately do a
sight line test and see whether it is up
inside the machine or not but if it's
like that then you might as well just
pull your [ __ ] shirt out and white
through the back talk about ripich here
look at that look at the quickness you
have stronger hands okay I don't think
this is an over-under issue I think this
is a hand strength issue
what are you doing how are you ripping
simple tear just by sheer gravity if you
do this then you can stop it with your
elbow boom I could have a martini a
cellphone whatever I wanted in this
other hand look how much further you had
to leave aesthetically can we agree that
over looks better when you go into hotel
rooms or cruise ships and they fold it
that nice little way internationally you
go into any bathroom
that's how Hanks internationally isn't
it different in the southern hemisphere
hotel is different than a home a hotel
represents an impersonal cold space that
other people have shared them not the
holidays I think top dollar
sometimes you need a lot of toilet paper
and you need it fast I gotta wipe two
holes watch this
wait sometimes three depending on what's
happening back there
you can stop it and rip it doesn't ready
to have that extra no you just pull it
out this way instead of slapping it like
a barbarian the problem however with
that is that once you do this you get
caught in the centripetal force of the
toilet paper and you waste too much
she's killing trees I just want the
proof is in the pudding there's one fly
this isn't even trees okay this is
chemically engineered material I think
having a spinner is like a really fun
addition once in a while okay well why
can't I do this we all put our toilet
paper in a different way I understand
that I don't think you're a lesser
person for hanging it like this
my major argument is just that the
effort it takes to tear off the piece of
paper with one hand is much simpler
under than over I have a problem with
the fact that you have a problem with
the fact that I sometimes hang it like
this if the toilet paper is on backwards
and I will call it backwards you have
all these unknown variables that you
can't predict now what happens if I
reach my little hand here to grab some
toilet paper in a public restroom
environment I don't want any surprises
holy [ __ ] there's enough surprises in
there already
oh my knuckles are bleeding everywhere
because when I go to rip the toilet
paper my knuckles have now scraped the
back of the wall your hands gonna be in
the same place whether you're pulling it
from the back on the front you're going
to pull it down some people have
hand-eye coordination and we can
actually use our hands in such a way
that doesn't cause personal injury oh I
think I could just tug down and do it I
think I just did it I think you feel
[ __ ]
I don't buy it or if I can pull it
forward I can pull it up it's all gonna
it's all unrolls it unrolls it's all and
rippled one hand just as easily as
listening to this I can double it over I
can do this the other way around risk
switch fingers switch fingers no no no
no no you had your chance to show your
elbow technique and I'm showing you my
wrist technique which is far superior
and then oh he's making fun of me cats
are like oh man you know it's fun
[ __ ] everything up that is the one
argument I've heard against over and
children but children are gonna [ __ ]
with everything so that's not as good
just goes around in a circle forever you
have a naughty dachshund he can't do
anything about this I don't
have cats that's one service I'm doing
the world but second this is not that
video then you get the posted video and
you get like all those likes you my
kitty did like you ran away with all the
toilet paper
we live in a free country and if I want
to hang it like this I can you hang like
this I don't trust you can we agree
though that we're just lucky to have to
paper and not be wiping with fleas or
our hands oh here's a really good thing
I think we can agree on though my
friends and I have this thing where we
don't buy cheap toilet paper that I
agree with but that super expensive
toilet paper dingleberry City
I'm ambidextrous in bathroom I avoid all
Clemen you're ambidextrous in the
bathroom I can only do anything with my
left hand if I tried to wipe with my
right hand I'd have a [ __ ] covered hand